[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg
guten Abend und willkommen mehr zum
Fußball-WM Halbfinale hat gleich Norbert
Lehmann schönen guten Abend
wir haben unter anderem diese Themen für
Sie
Anklage Nummer 4 Donald Trump muss im
US-Bundesstaat Georgia vor Gericht
grundlage ist ein Gesetz das gegen
kriminelle Banden eingesetzt wird
Beamtenbund schlägt Alarm Gewalt gegen
Beschäftigte im öffentlichen Dienst
nimmt zu das Vertrauen in die staatliche
Handlungsfähigkeit ab
und historischer Einzug ins Finale die
spanischen Fußballfrauen stehen erstmals
im Endspiel einer Weltmeisterschaft
[Musik]
das gab's noch nie in der US-Geschichte
mit Donald Trump muss sich ein
ehemaliger Präsident vor Gericht
verantworten und zwar mittlerweile in
vier Strafverfahren jetzt auch in
Georgia wegen seiner Versuche den
Ausgang der Präsidentenwahl 2020 dort zu
beeinflussen
Trump muss sich schon in Washington
wegen möglichen wahlbetrugsverantworten
und wegen seiner Rolle beim Sturm aufs
Kapital im Januar 2021 auch im
Zusammenhang mit schweigegeldzahlungen
an die Pornodarstellerin stormy Daniels
steht Trump vor Gericht und dann ist er
noch angeklagt weil er wichtige
Geheimakten in seinem privat Anwesen in
Florida aufbewahrt hat worum es jetzt
genau in Georgia geht dazu Claudia Bates
9 Uhr Abends im Gericht in Atlanta die
Geschworenen haben entschieden und
senden die Anklage zum Richter dieser
Stapel Akten enthält die Vorwürfe gegen
Donald Trump und 18 weitere Beschuldigte
die Angeklagten haben sich kriminell
bandenmäßig zusammengeschlossen um das
Ergebnis der Präsidentschaftswahl in
Georgia zu kippen
die Staatsanwältin wendet das sogenannte
ricoact an zur Bekämpfung organisierter
Kriminalität Donald Trump und seine
mutmaßlichen Komplizen darunter Anwälte
wie Rudi Giuliani werden Falschaussagen
vorgeworfen auch sollen sie Amtsträger
gedrängt haben ihren amtsei zu verletzen
da war der Anruf Trumps bei Georgia's
oberstem wahlaufseher dem Republikaner
bradfins Burger
ich möchte einfach nur
11.780 Stimmen finden
[Musik]
eine mehr als wir haben denn wir haben
den Staat gewonnen
jetzt beschimpft Trump wieder die
Staatsanwältin und beklagt sie mische
sich in die Präsidentschaftswahlen ein
und wolle ihn beschädigen
ich treffe Entscheidungen auf der
Grundlage von Fakten und Gesetzen das
Gesetz ist völlig unparteiisch so werden
die Entscheidungen in jedem Fall
getroffen
bis Freitag nächster Woche haben die
Angeklagten Zeit sich zu stellen
die Befugnisse des Präsidenten
Straftäter zu begnadigen reichen nicht
in die Justiz der Staaten hinein Trump
selbst als künftiger Präsident oder ein
anderer wohl meinen in der Präsident
könnte ihn also nicht begnadigen wenn
Trump in Georgia zu einer Haftstrafe
verurteilt wurde müsste er die auch
antreten
Außenministerin Anna Lena baerbock hat
ihre Reise in die Pazifik Region
abgebrochen das sei mehr als ärgerlich
schrieb sie in einer kurzbotschaft
zweimal hatte es an der
Regierungsmaschine vom Typ A340 die
gleiche Panne gegeben der Pilot musste
daraufhin zweimal große Mengen Kerosin
ablassen und zweimal nach Abu Dhabi
umkehren logistisch sein bärbox
Reisepläne nicht mehr zu retten gewesen
die beiden A340 der Flugbereitschaft der
Bundeswehr sollen jetzt vorzeitig
ausgemustert werden
ist es mehr als eine blöde Panne Theo
call
leider ja auch wenn man es natürlich
nicht überbewerten darf ist diese Panne
ein in die Welt ausstrahlendes Signal
die Deutschen die Weltmeister die
Perfektionisten die sind im doppelten
Sinn nicht mehr in der Lage zu einem
Höhenflug so ein Regierungsflugzeug ist
dann ein sehr plastisches pannensymbol
für die Wirtschaftsprognose die uns der
währungsfeuer kürzlich vorausgesagt hat
dass wir als einzige große
Industrienation ins Minus Steuern der
steht dann ein Flugzeug quasi als
Vertreter von made in Germany
unfreiwillig am Boden und natürlich gibt
es auch in der internationalen Welt so
etwas wie Helme aber mindestens genauso
bedauerlich ist der damit ausgefallene
vernetzungsbesuche in Australien und
Neuseeland in beide Länder werden in der
neuen multipolaren Welt der Zeiten Wände
immer wichtigere strategische Partner
sie helfen gegen Russland und wir gegen
China zuletzt war 2011 ein deutscher
Außenminister in Australien wenn die
deutsche Politik jetzt im Indopazifik
eine wichtigere Rolle spielen möchte
dann wäre es natürlich hilfreich diese
Bühne überhaupt zu erreichen danke schön
für diese Einschätzung aus Berlin
theokolade
was läuft schief bei den pannenfliegern
der Regierung auch Ihre Fragen dazu
beantwortet der Luftfahrt Experte
Andreas spät ab 19:30 Uhr bei ZDF heute
live zu sehen in unserer App oder auf
unseren Social Media Kanälen
planmäßig kam entwicklungsministerin
Schulze in Mauretanien an einem Land in
der afrikanischen saalzone dazu gehören
Niger und Mali beide Länder lösten mit
militärputschen regionale Krisen aus
dagegen gilt Mauretanien als stabil der
Westen setzt auf die demokratisch
gewählte Regierung als Partner auch weil
durch das 5 Millionen einwohnerland eine
hauptflüchtlingsroute nach Europa führt
Ines Trams
die Küste vor Mauretanien eines der
fischreichsten Gewässer der Erde dennoch
herrscht Hunger ein Drittel des
Fischfangs vergammelte bisher mit
deutscher Unterstützung lernen die
Menschen hier wie man mehr vom Fisch hat
so viel hat sich verändert wir haben nun
bessere Kisten und dazu Eis für den
Transport das hat die Qualität und die
Menge deutlich verbessert
zu Besuch die deutsche
entwicklungsministerin nach den putschen
in Mali und Niger will Berlin nicht
erneut enttäuscht werden vorsichtig
setzt man nun auf Mauretanien alles was
wir hier tun können um die Lage zu
stabilisieren hilft das ist hier ein
Epizentrum des Terrorismus einfach weil
so viele junge Leute auch so wenig
Perspektiven haben das heißt bei so
einem Projekt wie hier im Hafen
Arbeitsplätze zu schaffen Sicherheit zu
schaffen dass man seine Familie ernähren
kann das ist ein wichtiger Beitrag
Mauretanien eines der ärmsten Länder der
Welt politisch scheint es stabil wir
sind ein stabiles Land sagte
Wirtschaftsminister mit demokratischen
Strukturen und Wahlen ein Land in dem
unser Präsident auf politischen
Konsensus Wert legt und auf Befriedung
hunderttausend Flüchtlinge hat Moment
bereits aufgenommen 70% von ihnen
bleiben und ziehen nicht weiter nach
Europa auch das ist Deutschland wichtig
eine Fehleinschätzung wie bei Niger will
die Bundesregierung unbedingt vermeiden
klar ist die Lageeinschätzung muss
realistischer werden dennoch sieht man
sich gezwungen auf die letzte Demokratie
in der Sahel Region zu setzen
Mauretanien ein neuer Stabilitätsanker
in der Sahelzone Ministerin Schulze weiß
es gibt keine Garantie
nach Deutschland das Vertrauen in die
Handlungsfähigkeit des Staates schwindet
zunehmend das zeigt eine aktuelle
Umfrage für den deutschen Beamtenbund
demnach glauben nur noch 27 Prozent dass
der Staat in der Lage ist seine Aufgaben
zu erfüllen 80 Prozent der Befragten
äußerten zudem es gebe eine generelle
Verrohung der Gesellschaft auf der
Beamtenbund warnt die Gewalt gegenüber
Mitarbeitenden im öffentlichen Dienst
nimmt zu Alexander röttig
Schläge abblocken Messer abwehren Sven
nötenverordnungsdienst der Stadt Aachen
trainiert regelmäßig bei Ausbilder
Volker Haupt es geht rauer zu auf den
Straßen das haben beide schmerzhaft
erfahren von kapselanrissen über eine
bisunde angespuckt von der infektiösen
Person Beleidigungen und natürlich die
Social Media Sache sind ja die ganze
Breite ist dabei ich habe einmal einen
Kollegen erlebt der selber Nothilfe
leisten musste während einer Kollegin ja
fast erwirkt worden ist und ich kann
Ihnen sagen wenn sie solche Menschen
erleben in der Nachsorge da fließen
trennen mehr als die Hälfte der
Mitarbeiter des öffentlichen Dienstes
hat Gewalt oder Beleidigungen erlebt das
zeigt die Studie des Beamtenbundes bei
Polizistinnen und Polizisten sind es
sogar 64% bei Feuerwehrleuten die
Menschen zu Hilfe kommen und 41% bei
Lehrerinnen und Lehrern 37 das geht
überhaupt nicht und da sind wir als
Gesellschaft auch gefordert also nicht
nur die Politik sondern wir alle
gemeinsam das eben auch anzuprangern und
hinter die Beschäftigten des
öffentlichen Dienstes auch hier zu
stehen die Kommunen rüsten derweil auf
auch die Amtsräume im Aachener Sozialamt
gibt es strikte Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
Zutritt nur mit Termin und für den
Ernstfall eine notfallcode der Kollegen
alarmiert ist gab schon einen schweren
Übergriff auf eine Mitarbeiterin also
einmal PC runtergeworfen Schreibtisch
also umgeschmissen Schranktüren
aufgerissen und die Kollegen ist halt
auch ja hat das Büro verlassen musste
fliehen Ordnungskräfte üben Nahkampf
Bürgerbüros brauchen Alarmanlagen Beamte
sind Repräsentanten des Staates immer
mehr Menschen reagieren an ihnen ihren
Frust ab
nach Russland dort hat die Zentralbank
den Leitzins sehr deutlich erhöht von
8,5 auf 12%. damit wir sie die
steigenden Preise bekämpfen und den
Verfall der Landeswährung Rubel an den
Körper in Moskau
was steckt hinter dieser Entscheidung
und was bedeutet sie fürs russische Volk
der Hintergrund ist das in Russland
Angebot und Nachfrage immer weiter
auseinander gehen Präsident Putin stellt
die Wirtschaft immer weiter in Richtung
Kriegswirtschaft um das heißt während
immer mehr Rüstungsgüter produziert
werden fehlen die Arbeitskräfte für alle
anderen Branchen auch weil viele Männer
an der Front in der Ukraine kämpfen oder
das Land schon verlassen haben dazu
kommt dann noch der sanktionsbedingte
Mangel an Komponenten für die Produktion
in allen Bereichen für die Bevölkerung
heißt das dass eine Kredite absehbar
teurer werden werden das trifft eine
Gesellschaft die ohnehin von
Überschuldung bedroht ist dass die
deshalb aber jetzt gegen ihre Führung
auf die Barrikaden geht ist in
Anbetracht der drakonischen Strafen die
da drohen nicht zu erwarten
live aus Moskau Armin Körper vielen Dank
kaum zu ermessen ist das Leid dass der
russische Angriffskrieg den Ukrainern
bringt nach wie vor gibt es keine
offiziellen Zahlen zu gefallen nennen es
dürften viele tausende sein für die
Familien ist jeder einzelne eine
Tragödie eine Brille hat eine Frau
begleitet die es sich zur Aufgabe
gemacht hat die Leichen der Gefallenen
nach Hause zu bringen
wir treffen uns mit Natalia rodrigres in
razon fast jeden Tag kommt sie her holt
Leichen von gefallenen Soldaten um sie
den Familien zu übergeben
wie schwer ist das
wissen sie der Mensch gewöhnt sich an
alles aber das ist etwas woran man sich
nicht gewöhnen kann
ihr Job ist gefährlich reson ist Front
statt die Russen sind nah auch Natalia
wurde schon beschossen
in der Gerichtsmedizin haben sie ihr
einen weißen Leichen Sack ins Auto
geladen erst jetzt der fährt sie wen sie
transportiert er wurde im Jahr 1980
geboren ich hole Serie ab
eigentlich ist Natalia Juristin Mutter
von drei Kindern als der Krieg ausbrach
hat sie sich freiwillig gemeldet
wenn du diese Funktion erfüllst die
Gefallenen transportierst wenn du
verstehst dass es deine Waffenbrüder
sind dann verstehst du das ist das
verlorene Leben deines Volkes ist jedes
Leben ist die ganze Welt
der Sack fürjewski steht schon bereit
alles wird von den Streitkräften
organisiert sag Kreuz Blumenschmuck
jeder der hier ist denkt darüber nach
dass dieser Tag der letzte sein kann
Tod und Trauer überall dabei sind sich
Natalia so sehr nach Frieden
ich hoffe sehr darauf dass dieser Krieg
endet jeder Mensch der hier lebt hofft
dass der Krieg zu Ende geht
das Schlimmste steht Natalia noch bevor
die Beerdigung und die Begegnung mit den
Angehörigen erst dann sagt sie begreife
sie den Verlust
die Zahl der Todesopfer nach den Bränden
auf Hawaii steigt weiter an 99 Tote
wurden bislang entdeckt der Gouverneur
von Hawaii rechnet damit dass sich die
Zahl verdoppeln wird die Suche nach
Opfern in hunderten ausgebrannten
Häusern und Fahrzeugen sei ausgesprochen
mühsam und gefährlich
Deutschland hat ein Klimaschutzziel bis
2030 soll der Anteil erneuerbarer
Energien auf mindestens 80% steigen
zurzeit sind es
46,2 Prozent die meiste Energie kommt
aus Windkraft dahinter liegen
fotoweltaik Biogas und Wasserkraft wie
Wind noch effektiver zu nutzen ist dazu
forscht das Zentrum für luft-
Krummendeich in nordniedersachsen
flaches Land Wind ist hier oben alles
andere als Mangelware also der richtige
Ort um ein Windenergie zu forschen das
Ziel effizient und Akzeptanz der Anlagen
zu verbessern ja beabsichtigen eine
ganzheitliche Untersuchung der
Windenergie hier zu machen das heißt wir
haben hier eine komplette
Instrumentierung in den Anlagen drin von
Fundament bis hin ja zu den Blattspitzen
sind Sensoren verbaut und können damit
dann die Windenergie als
gesamtkonzert quasi untersuchen auch
wenn es Windräder schon seit langem gibt
der erste Windpark in Deutschland wurde
1987 eröffnet ist es immer noch ein
recht junger Industriezweig so gibt es
immer noch viele offene Fragen die nur
mit Forschung im Originalmaßstab
beantwortet werden können
die Auswirkungen der ersten Anlage auf
die zweite Anlage zu erforschen ist
deshalb wichtig weil es im Zusammenhang
mit dem Zubau mit den zunehmenden
Energie immer wieder die Situation geben
wird das eine Anlage die andere Anlage
abschattet das für dazu dass die zweite
Anlage den Windschatten steht zum einen
weniger Energie erzeugt und zum anderen
aber auch Höhe Lasten sieht und dadurch
höher verschlissen wird jede Menge
zahlen und Messergebnisse werden auf der
Anlage gesammelt dieser Mast z.B liefert
meteorologische Daten alle Informationen
sind der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich ein
besonderes Interesse daran dürfte aber
die Industrie haben
der Tierschutzbund schlägt Alarm viele
Tierheime stünden vor dem Kollaps sie
seien überfüllt mit Tieren die Menschen
unüberlegt angeschafft haben und wieder
loswerden wollten dazu kommen die
gestiegenen Kosten für die Heime aber
auch für die Halter viele können sich
Hund oder Katze einfach nicht mehr
leisten Luisa hupen
wenn Sprechstunde ist muss immer jemand
im Büro sein so häufig klingelt im
Tierheim Stuttgart aktuell das Telefon
wir möchten Sie gern abgeben okay es ist
Urlaubszeit da wollen immer mehr Leute
Tiere abgeben diesen Sommer aber ist es
extrem viele hatten sich im Homeoffice
ein Tier zugelegt jetzt fehlen Zeit und
Mittel die Leute haben kein Geld mehr
und von dem her muss man irgendwo
einsparen und bei sich selber spart mir
sehr ungern ein also kommt es geliebte
Tier als erstes Weg die Haltungskosten
sind gestiegen vor allem Tierarztkosten
zuletzt und durchschnittlich 30% so kam
auch Georgie hierher
der Besitzer konnte seine Behandlung
nicht mehr bezahlen wir haben ihn
operieren lassen weil die Pfote
zertrümmert war und jetzt ist er hier
deutschlandweit kommen laut
Tierschutzbund pro Jahr 300.000 Tiere in
Heimen unter diese finanzieren sich zum
Großteil über Spenden die Stadt
Stuttgart überlegt sich auch übernimmt
20% der jährlichen Kosten dafür müssen
sie hier auch Tiere aufnehmen die
gefunden oder von Behörden beschlagnahmt
werden zu lange habe man sich auf das
Engagement der Tierschützer verlassen
klagt der Tierschutzbund und fordert
mehr Investitionen wir haben alte
Bausubstanz die weder energetisch auf
dem neuesten Stand ist noch in der
Fläche die vielen Tiere jetzt so gut
versorgen kann dass wir wirklich viele
Plätze haben es ist nie Geld da gewesen
die Rücklagen der Vereine sind
aufgebraucht den Kommunen haben sich
extrem billig über Jahrzehnte aus ihrer
Pflichtaufgabe herausgekauft bei einer
Anfrage mal nein sagen das fällt den
Tierschützern in Stuttgart schwer sie
werden weiter versuchen alle verstoßenen
Tiere unterzubringen
der Südwesten Frankreichs nein der
spanischen Grenze ist eine beliebte
Urlaubsregion am Mittelmeer dort hat die
Feuerwehr einen Waldbrand unter
Kontrolle gebracht zuvor waren
vorsorglich mehrere Campingplätze mit
rund 3000 Touristen evakuiert worden
inzwischen konnten die meisten Urlauber
zurückkehren das Feuer war gestern
Nachmittag ausgebrochen ein Campingplatz
und mehrere Häuser wurden größtenteils
zerstört
und bei der Fußball-WM stehen die ersten
Finalistinnen fest Norbert die
Spanierinnen das erste Mal übrigens dass
das Nationalteam das WM-Finale erreicht
die Spanierinnen wieder offensiv stark
die Schwedinnen wieder defensiv gut
organisiert ein csringen alle drei Tore
fielen in der Schlussphase
sie haben es geschafft nach einem Spiel
das erst in den letzten 10 Minuten so
richtig Fahrt aufnimmt 80 Minute und die
eingewechselte Salma platziert perfekt
1:0 für Spanien die Schwedinnen jetzt
gefordert 88 Minute Blomquist vom VfL
Wolfsburg ebenfalls eingewechselt mit
ganz viel Gefühl das einst zu eins eine
Minute später die ibererin in Olga 16
Meter spanien führt wieder musowicz im
Tor sieht etwas unglücklich aus es ist
der Punkt auf sie nach einer
dramatischen Schlussphase 2:1 ein
glückliches Ende für Erfurter
ja und auf wen die Spanierinnen im
Finale am Sonntag treffen das
entscheidet sich morgen Mittag Heil nun
in Sydney das Überraschungsteam der WM
Australien gegen Europameister England
Euphorie und Zuversicht den Down Under
sind grenzenlos
Australien ist auf den Geschmack
gekommen nach dramatischem
Elfmeterschießen gegen Frankreich hoffen
die Mathildas wieder auf die
Unterstützung ihrer Fans während die
Europameisterin nur nicht so
beunruhigend widerstandsfähig wer wie
England trotz wechselhafter Leistung ins
Halbfinale vorstößt weiß dass er noch
zulegen kann an lautstarke gegnerische
Fans konnten sie sich gegen die
Kolumbianerinnen im Viertelfinale
gewöhnen trotz Rückstands blieben die
Engländerinnen unbeeindruckt und
entschieden das Spiel für sich
Australien Fieber gegen England einen
weiteren Showdown entgegen
und das WM Finale am Sonntag live bei
uns hier im ZDF zu sehen ab 11 Uhr
der brasilianische Fußballprofi Neymar
ist der nächste Topstar der nach
Saudi-Arabien wechselt das bestätigten
soweit sowohl niemals bisheriger Verein
Paris als auch sein neuer Club alle
Hilal in Saudi Arabien stehen unter
anderem bereits Cristiano Ronaldo und
Karin Benzema unter Vertrag
bei den European para Championships in
Rotterdam haben die Deutschen
rollstuhlbasketballerinnen ihr letztes
Gruppenspiel gegen Spanien mit 58 zu 45
gewonnen
so Halbzeit hatte Deutschland bereits
sechs Punkte Vorsprung auch nach der
Pause überzeugten das Team vom
bundestrainer Dirk Passiva durch
flüssige Kombination durch diesen Sieg
steht Deutschland im Halbfinale gelingt
der Einzug ins Endspiel ja dann wäre das
Team für die Paralympics nächstes Jahr
in Paris qualifiziert
also drücken wir morgen fest die Daumen
ja natürlich in Bayern warnt der
Deutsche Wetterdienst aktuell vor
schwerem Gewitter mit extrem heftigem
Starkregen und Hagel und auch
morgendrohen Gewitter mehr zu den
Aussichten gleich von Katja horneffer
das heute journal mit Anne gallinek um
viertel vor zehn danke und tschüss und
bis morgen wenn Sie mögen machen sie es
gut
[Musik]
guten Abend im Schlepptau von tief Bernd
haben sich kräftige Schauer und Gewitter
entwickelt die höchsten Wolken haben wir
für sie rot eingefärbt daran erkennen
sie sehr schön wie diese Gewitter von
Südwest nach Nordost über Deutschland
hinwegziehen auch heute Nachmittag gab
es schon kräftige Gewitter und auch
jetzt am Abend und in der Nacht werden
die sich weiter ausbreiten bis in
Richtung Ostsee die größte
Gewittergefahr geht aber wohl von diesen
Gewittern in Niederbayern aus da können
örtlich eng begrenzt 50 Liter Regen pro
Quadratmeter in kurzer Zeit fallen und
das bedeutet dann dass Lokal Keller und
Straßen überflutet werden kann im Westen
ist die Nacht viel ruhiger die
Temperaturen sinken auf 20 Grad in der
Lausitz und 12 Grad an der Nordsee und
steigen morgen auf 21 Grad auf den
Ostfriesischen Inseln und bis 32 Grad im
Breisgau der Tag beginnt erstmal ganz
freundlich aber schon am Vormittag
gibt's die ersten Kräft igeren Gewitter
hier in den östlichen Mittelgebirgen
nachmittags dann auch weiter im Westen
es wird sich am Donnerstag nicht so
allzu viel ändern Freitag und Samstag
werden noch ein bisschen wärmer und der
Gewitter Schwerpunkt zieht etwas nach
Nordosten guten Abend